my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to your dear Mother and you'll
want to leave me to burn the spot
because alone why don't we just bring
him nah I don't think so
you hear this ladies he's worried his
immigrant father's gonna make it look
like some kind of Goomba all right
listen if we're gonna do this Dad you
gotta dial it down
what is this
wow this is amazing
huh it's called love and affection then
unlike you when you met me at the
delivery room you chose to shake my hand
what else was I supposed to do we just
met
Sebastian I don't know how you're going
to fit in
Waiting
don't these people have jobs they got
their money in the stock market that
mayonnaise jars buried in their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
we'll give you the grand tour this is
Doug he's learning to be a Healer hello
what are you doing just serenading our
pet peacock
I love you these people are strange they
have birds for pets he's like
[Music]
are just a bunch of goddamn
show-offs if you ask me
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you were going to spend the
whole time embarrassing me how could you
say that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I can die I'm
trying to make sure that you don't make
an ass out of yourself by trying to be
somebody you're not
oh my god oh Sebastian your suit
it's Versace do you like it no you
it's not up
I
would love to make a full Italian dinner
for everybody we don't keep a lot of
food here Amanda scalco always finds a
way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe we put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's artichoke and poultry
absolutely
[Music]
oh no
you slide up their pet pee packed and
you thought I was crazy for worrying
that you were gonna make us look like
some bad Italian staff that's right to
help me get rid of the evidence why does
it seem like you've done this before